ladies and gentlemen two-time Academy
Award winner Miss Jane Fonda
tonight we honor extraordinary
achievements in all areas of motion
picture production for 1988 a year in
which it can truly be said the world
went back to the movies the members of
this Academy have chosen five out of the
eligible films these exceptional movies
range across the spectrum of human
experience covering topics as diverse as
autism racism career ISM sexism
voyeurism
and tourism accidental and otherwise you
want isms we got them as the evening
progresses we're going to show you
scenes from each of the five nominees
and by the way this in no way excuses
you from going to see the movies
themselves and I mean see them in a
theater you want to watch videotapes I
know some terrific videotapes you can
watch our first nominee for Best Picture
is Rain Man
it's about what happens when a slick
young hustler discovers his long-lost
older brother an autistic savant
the brothers are played and played
magnificently by Dustin Hoffman and Tom
Cruise in this scene the younger brother
inadvertently triggers the memory in his
older brother's mind a memory that
provides a clue a very vital clue to
what happened to them in their childhood
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
a man who was my father's best friend
and a part of my life when I was growing
up he's here tonight with one of the
screens great beauties you'll remember
them from Hitchcock's film vertigo but I
know them as Jimmy Stewart and Kim Novak
well Kim you know I could have gone up
there and walked down with you but as
you know I'm afraid of heights now if
you haven't have on these shoes chilly I
mean then you would have something to be
afraid about well I think if I was
wearing those shoes I'd be afraid of a
lot of things in a lot a lot of things
have be afraid of me we're here to
present the awards tonight to the
gentleman who makes sure that the
audience hears every sigh each whisper
even never you know the sound Awards
well you've certainly piqued me Maya
I feel very honored giving this award
I've always enjoyed very good
relationship with with the sound man
unfortunately they sometimes a run run
out of tape the four - II finished my
line
the award for achievement in sound will
go to one of these masterful teams
less fresh Holtz dick Alexander burn
poor and we'll Edie Britt who showcased
the music of the great Charlie Parker
and burns
dan Vasko heaven f Cleary Richard
Overton and Al Overton who blew up the
new box building and diehard Andy Nelson
Bryan Saunders and Peter Hanford who
faithfully recorded all the idle chatter
of gorillas in the mist
Robert let's Elliott Tyson Rick Klein
and Danny Michael who made sure that we
understood all the actors even when they
were wearing hoods in Mississippi
Burning
Robert Knutson John Boy Donna Shalala
and Tony da who brilliantly captured all
the tunes sung by all the tunes and Who
Framed Roger Rabbit an Oscar goes to
Bart
oh good afternoon I think I thank you
I'm so happy this is my fourth
nomination and I don't know what to say
other than I'm so delighted these
wonderful people with me hear less
threshold and Vern pore and dick like
Alexander thank you for everything I'd
like to thank David Valdes also Clint
Eastwood and my also my boom man Marvin
Lewis and Robert Harris thank you thank
you for everything